here's what i think canceling is and why
it's different from criticism
criticism is expressing an argument or
opinion with the idea
of rationally influencing public opinion
through public persuasion interpersonal
persuasions canceling
comes from the universe of propaganda
not critical discourse
and it's about organizing or
manipulating a social environment
or a media environment with a goal or
predictable effect of isolating or
de-platforming
or intimidating an ideological opponent
it's about making an
idea or a person socially radioactive
today you'll hear the activists say
well i didn't read the thing i don't
need to read the thing to know that it's
colonialist or racist
so an open society is a place that has a
lot of intellectual pluralism a lot of
diversity of viewpoints
it tries to pit bias and prejudice
against other biases and prejudice
and it does that right forcing
contention and critical argument and
forcing people to persuade each other
over time that's really what science is
that's really what journalism is the
open society is not only incomparably
better at producing knowledge than any
other society
because it allows us to make errors and
not
be punished for making errors it allows
us to make errors in fact
much more quickly that's the secret of
science i call it liberal science
the magic of liberal sciences in the
institutions that
force us to channel these conversations
in socially productive ways
if you're an academic you're writing for
journals you're undergoing peer review
you're being credentialed by some kind
of
scientific organization if you're a
journalist you submit to ethics codes
you probably work for an organization
where you're supposed to tell the truth
all of these things are mediated in ways
which allow us to be individuals but
also to understand some rules of
engagement
to follow each other society where you
don't have that or community
like say twitter or like say an academic
culture where it's student to student
and peer to peer
where you don't have that kind of
mediation going on the social fabric
turns into
kind of lord of the flies who can gang
up on who
who can make the most noise who can
attract the most followers
and you begin to display to each other
instead of talking to each other
weirdly the way to help us be more
liberated as individuals is to
strengthen the institutions that we use
to connect each other this is not a
fight between one set of people and
another set of people it is also a fight
within ourselves
there are ideas that each of us hate
that it's very hard to restrain
ourselves from not ganging up on in an
illiberal way
the idea that wrong-headed and dangerous
and heretical and blasphemous ideas
should be not only allowed but protected
is preposterous it's ridiculous no
society has ever had that idea
until about 250 years ago it shouldn't
work
but here we are and the reason is
because despite its ridiculousness it
has the one great advantage of being the
single most successful social principle
ever invented
you